general is Ukraine losing the war
against Russian sponsored separatists I
wouldn't want to characterize it in
those terms what I would say is that the
situation in eastern Ukraine over the
last seven to ten days has deteriorated
we see the russian-backed forces moving
west past the original mints line of
contact that was agreed and this is not
a good situation and we see immense
pressure on the Ukrainian forces in the
D belts AV region and so this is
concerning in the wake of the ongoing
European Peace Initiative what could be
NATO's role to assist Ukraine more
effectively so first and foremost we
support patient peace initiatives we
believe that we have to have a
diplomatic and political solution in the
east and so in we should approach this
in unity to bring strength to those
negotiations and the second part of the
question I'm sorry what NATO could do to
assist Ukraine more effectively so NATO
is already assisting Ukraine as you know
NATO has taken several lines of effort
NATO has raised some funds that are
being used to to assist the Ukrainian
military we are helping their
ministerial level understand and begin
to adapt to their military situation
build capacities in those ministries to
help the Ukrainians and we have given
many of the NATO nations not NATO but
the NATO nations have of course supplied
non-lethal aid to this point so NATO is
already involved in helping the
Ukrainians but there's a debate among
allies whether this is enough whether
there shouldn't be lethal weapons
shipped to Ukraine in order that the
country can defend itself what's your
position on that so there is a debate
out there and my position is that we
have an entire toolkit of tools to use
in this fight we need to keep the
diplomatic pressure
on Russia to solve this problem we need
to win and and continue to fight in the
information space to address the false
narrative that is being put out there by
Russia about what is going on their
involvement in what's going on we as
military men and women support those
efforts that the nation's outside of
NATO and inside of NATO the EU and
others are taking economically to bring
pressure on Russia those are three tools
that are already being used the last
tool is the military tool and I do not
think that we should out of hand
preclude the use of some military what
exactly what precisely could that be the
use of some military so this is being
discussed what we have been asked by
Ukrainians to consider are groups of
capabilities to to address an artillery
issue to address combat jamming radio
jamming and communications capabilities
to address counter mobility capabilities
against these armored forces etc so
there are several groups of of aid that
the Ukrainians have asked us to consider
Russia's warfare against Ukraine is
described as being unconventional or
hybrid has NATO yet the strategy and the
means to respond to that challenge to
that threat so this is the topic du jour
the the hybrid thread and what we need
to remember is that the hybrid threat is
just a combination of conventional means
which we understand and unconventional
means there's really no new threats in
the hybrid war what is new or what is
different is the way that they used them
how they bring all the tools of the
hybrid toolkit to bear on the opponent
or in this case Ukraine intense
diplomatic pressure on keeve as I said
mentioned before an intense
disinformation campaign to discredit
keeve to confuse the situation on the
ground to confuse the Russian
involvement in what's
on the ground economic warfare in the
form of pressure on energy in the form
of pressure on recalling loans etc and
then clearly the Russian forces are
involved militarily in this so this
whole of government approach to putting
pressure on Ukraine is this hybrid
warfare so tools we recognize but used
in a new and and combined way thank you
very much general